l'ONU estime qu'au moins 2 milliards de
personnes sont privées d'accès à l'eau
et à l'assainissement certains de nos
territoires européens sont également
impactés tel la plupart de nos régions
ultrapériphériques ces citoyens
européens supportent des retards
structurel dans le renouvellement des
infrastructures mais aussi les
conséquences du changement climatique à
Mayotte la quasi-ttalité des habitants
n'a accès à l'eau qu'un jour sur 3 c'est
insupportable cela entraîne des f
fermure d'écoes et de graves risques
sanitaires notamment la France a mis en
œuvre les moyens nécessaires pour parer
au plus urgent cependant l'ampleur des
mesures à mettre en œuvre nécessite une
meilleure prise en compte des réalités
dans les régions ultrapériphériques il
convient de mettre en place un
accompagnement adapté avec des
stratégies d'accès à l'eau efficace un
renforcement des investissements du
soutien technique pour moderniser les
réseaux d'eau grâce au féir notamment si
Mayotte est la plus touchée d' Rupe
nécessite également une mobilisation
générale